they fear us now they really recognize
that the writing is on the wall in the
long term they're going to lose this but
of course you're going to have to go to
go kicking and screaming prop 19 was a
little bit ahead of the times it did
impressively well forty-six percent of
the vote and a strongly Republican
off-year election and it opened new
ground in the whole drug debate because
the first time we had a real attempt to
legalize marijuana in a manner somewhat
similar to alcohol it had a lot of
problems with it that opened it up to
attack by the public um not just by our
side but by the crucial middle twenty
percent of Californians who you need to
convince that you've got a workable
solution one of the big problems with
prop 19 was that it established a very
decentralized regime where it would be
up to each city and county to decide
whether marijuana was legal there or not
there wouldn't be a uniform statewide
system will particularly like that in
California we regulate alcohol on a
statewide basis and the state
constitution is she would have written
an offer from a very state centric
standpoint so that brought a lot of
questions and then the other big issue
was working in driving under the
influence there was a unfortunate clause
in prop 19 which I supported a lot of us
would support but which didn't have to
be in the initiative that said that
workers would have should have the right
to use marijuana so long as they weren't
under the influence but that raised a
red flag and bought in the chamber of
commerce and heavy
in industry and to oppose it as well and
that was wheeled out in the public's
mind so we shouldn't have raised that
red flag but beyond all that I think
really one of the crucial questions is
you know would it actually ever happen
or not we were trying to promise the
voters a billion dollars or more in
taxes and you know revenues from a legal
market I think a lot of California's
might have thought yeah but that's not
going to happen we're going to end up
with a lawsuit instead and this is not
real we still have a low fifty percent
majority in concept but you know in
order to present something that will
really get a majority vote you have to
give the voters a plan that they can
have confidence and if they think that
the state and federal governments think
the officials are going to not support
this law and work to defeat it and that
is in fact the situation they're not
going to have confidence in the outcomes
you know if we would get the federal
government to just say hey we'll make
this work I think there would be no
problem and I think that the people
would go along instantly I do not expect
legalization to be on the ballot in 2012
in California we are investigating the
possibility of having a medical
marijuana reform initiative on the
ballot because there are lots of
problems with California's medical
marijuana law or lack thereof its
disputed in California weather
dispensaries are even legal entities
depending on where you are in the state
we have you know this enormous edibles
industry we've made all sorts of strides
and developing new kinds of
cannabis edibles and extracts none of it
is really legal under the law we have
delivery services all of these things
should be legally recognized and written
into the law even though and everybody
feels as widespread abuse that anybody
can really get a recommendation if they
want it you know good doctors
advertising set up tents even at this
very festival and the price is gotten
down as low as 35 dollars now an
Internet doctor's recommendation or
whatever oh sure but on the other hand
it isn't actually causing any problems
so Californians are actually comfortable
with a medical marijuana regime that we
have at the moment but if you change it
to us adult you sales that means anybody
can come from out of state from New York
they can fly in by their pot take it I
mean you're telling me that the federal
government is not going to try to do
something about this you bet they are
we've still got a ways to go and you
really have to work I think on federal
law as well we've got to get rid of this
whole federal noose that you know
prevents any local experimentation or
wrong
you